all right hello everyone
I'm Daniel I am currently a PhD student
at Virginia Tech
doing pretty much switched my thesis
topic a couple months ago doing data
science education mainly focus for
medical practitioners so if you work in
medicine if you're a physician or a
nurse let's talk about how you can learn
R or Python this past summer this past
summer I was an intern at our studio and
I worked on a package called grade this
which is a code grader for learn our
documents so if you are in the education
space and you want to create something
like like a data camp lesson or
Codecademy lesson in that type of style
you can do that yourself and then this
is an Auto grader that tries to say hey
I expected you to use the function
called some when you use the function
called mean and I learned very quickly
that to generate that sentence is very
difficult so I am also like Jared said I
wrote this book about this other
programming language and this is what
this talk is about because we are at our
conference and I'm going to talk about
Python so ironpython all I did was just
Google like Python in our popularity and
I just took the first link and this was
really just a slide that says maybe
Python is something to look at and pay
attention to I just saw a tweet this
morning that pretty much said Python
just surpassed Java as the second most
popular language in something because I
don't remember the rest of the tweet but
it's if the past job I mean that means
something especially for the enterprise
world so so what is Python well it is a
general-purpose programming language
depending on where you are and who you
are talking to it may not be the best at
everything or anything but one of at
PyCon one of the things I did here was
it is probably second best at everything
and that's pretty good
to be the second best language at
everything what Python does better than
R which is the only updates I've made
since I finished my talk was updating a
few things where our how Python handles
environments so if you've tried to ever
pin packages or our virgins it's a
little bit more difficult than how you
were doing in Python just the other day
a package called RM was released so hope
figures crossed that might make life a
little bit better and one thing
objectively I can say Python throws
better than R is in the field or in the
world of web development and hardware so
if you ever see this this is a little
circuit board by Adafruit and it's
running a circuit python so that is my
name tag code in Python so what what I
really do like about R is the world of
communication it does a really great job
at if you have done a piece of data
analysis and you need to present it to
other people so stuff like shiny and our
markdown are probably you know that is
the reason why if I do an analysis in
Python it comes back into our if only
for ggplot or if only for like putting
it on dashboard for guys so the
inspiration for this talk came from over
the summer when Max Kuhn told me to say
hey you're an intern so you have to give
this talk for me now and I pretty much
gave a 40 minute version of a four hour
workshop on like this is the differences
between R and Python so you can see
those notes there it was written in
Jupiter notebooks and it uses the rise
reveal plug-in and it was pretty slow
and what I realized right before my talk
was I could just I could have just use
our markdown reticulate to create my
slides and so that's what this talk
isn't using so ironpython so let's just
give an example we can use R to load
data set so here is the Billboard
dataset from Hadleys tidy data paper we
can use the plier and select to rename
to select some columns and rename the
artists column we can tidy the data set
using tidy are right now we're using
pivot longer so that is the equivalent
of spread in the previous version and
then we can use something like per to do
some additional
cleaning one thing that if you didn't
know when you'd write something like
function X some kind of thing and then X
like that that it's exactly the same
thing as this notation this tilde
formula notation so if you've ever seen
like why people use this formula
notation in a purse statement just know
that those two lines are equivalent that
period essentially is a placeholder for
two letter X so we can actually replay
repeat that same analysis in Python so
we can load up pandas which gives Python
the data frame object we can load up
brie for regular expressions and Emily
showed the janitor package in our well
there is the equivalent package in
Python written by Erik McCall janitor
that tries to implement the same things
I wrote a package called pi prod root
and implement it the here function in
Python just like the version R and then
we can load up and do our data analysis
just like we did in our and people
usually give me a lot of grief saying
that I like are over Python because
Python doesn't have pipes
well Python kind of has pipes it's
called method chaining and so you can
see you can pretty much write your code
and look down just like you would a deep
I or pipeline so how do you interact
with arm Python or is a package called
reticulate and lets you call python from
our it gives you a translation layer
between r and python objects and unless
you load up individual Python
environments so how do we use this we
can load up the reticulate library I am
in the data science field and a lot of
data scientists use anaconda so we are
using Condor environments you can load
we can this is just code because I was
jumping around between Windows and a
Linux machine but I'm just using my
default mini condo environment and we
can use the use conda m in that
environment and then what you have done
is registered your Python environment in
R if you do this at home realize that
once you run use environment if you want
to pick a different environment you have
then we start your our session just
running the command again won't actually
change your Python environment so we
have this Python script we have a data
set a data frame this is exactly the
same things before and we can run
something like a group by and a me
to get another VAT value and you can
source this as a script if you want in
to our using reticulate source Python
and you'll notice that you can actually
just have those variables straight into
your environment right like you source a
Python file and all sudden like those
exact variable names just and exist and
here we get a vector mean ranked by week
and then we actually get a regular data
frame and this is an R data frame even
though it's a script written in Python
and there's an entire translation layer
between like R objects and Python
objects if they source they just come
into R so for example you just saw a
panda's data frame object being loaded
into an RD a different mode so let's go
through an example from machine learning
so there's a library called psych hit
learn the API for succulent learn was
sort of the inspiration from executing
to put together carrot and parsnip which
was just a unified API to fit you
machine learning models secular and has
a function called load breast-cancer to
load a breast-cancer data set and the
weird thing about python is there isn't
really a consistent way of loading data
from packages so in scikit-learn you get
this thing called a bunch but you can
use like c born to load up the tips data
frame tips data set and you get a data
frame object so things are a little bit
inconsistent you have to check the
documentation for it in the cancer data
set there is a column orders a value
called target which is the response
variable or the Y variable there's also
an variable called data and that is the
actual matrix so scikit-learn runs
everything on a matrix it can handle
data frame objects but by default
everything is a matrix we can use
scikit-learn to Train test split our
data so pre-processing is done through
scikit-learn
we can use a min/max scalar to scale our
data and then we can transform our x
training set this way in python and then
we can create a support vector machine
for classification using SVM fit put in
our training data put in our value for
our response values and then we'll fit a
model and then by default scikit-learn
has the ability to score our data set in
this case that the fault metric is
called accuracy so we can do that same
exact thing in our
we can load up reticulate for example
you can see I'm loading up my Python
environment using reticulate if I really
wanted to I can use reticulate to you to
load in that breast cancer data set from
a python library and create an our data
frame out of python libraries so you can
use it for that and we can use a
combination of our sample and recipes
which is the new way of creating machine
learning pipelines in our to essentially
set up train tests split and do our data
transformations in R and then we can use
parsnip to say hey this is the support
vector machine that I want to fit and
you can get an entire table here in your
official documentation for parsnip so
the support vector machine comes from
kern lab so you have to make sure you
have that installed as well and then in
our there is a library called yardstick
that does the model evaluation so here
we can say yardstick accuracy to get the
accuracy score and it should be pretty
much the same minus the third decimal
point so I talked about communication so
we fitted a model what about
communication so this presentation it's
written in our Martins arrogant slide
decks and all of the Python code you see
were actually just live executed in my
presentation so all I did was and one in
the earlier two chunks I library
reticulate set up my environment and
then I've had a CO chunk and instead of
R as the driver
I changed the nimpah Python and it'll
load up and execute my Python code so
all of the Python code you just saw was
not copy and pasted was actually live
executed and I hit NIT on this thing
two days ago and not as I was plugging
in the the projector like I did last
year so sharing objects between R and
Python so in an are chunk if you are
using R markdown you can access all of
your Python variables using py dollar
signs so you get a variable called py
and you can say py dollar sign to access
everything from the Python bar
likewise if your created variables in
our chunk and
one access sorry if you create a
variables and yes in our trunk and you
want to use them in a Python chunk you
get a variable called lowercase R and
Python and you can access all of your
our stuff using our dot notice it's a
period or dot and that's not the end of
a sentence dot so in a Python trunk I
can for example this is the test data
set and I'm just saying let's just get
the reverser of our data set and this is
our Python data set and in our we can
say hey py dollar sign give me that
variable from the Python world and save
it to a single observation in R so now I
get our object from a piece of code that
was executing Python so you can do you
can do that and create variables in one
language create variables another
language fit models and one in the other
and just pass stuff around right so we
created this SVM object in Python and
you say hey in this SVM object just run
a prediction right so in this example
it's kind of like nonsensical I'm using
my training my test data to do a
prediction but we can say hey here's
this Python object don't make a
prediction but here's also this R vector
and pass that into my Python model
object and they both work so you can do
the same thing the other way around you
can rake in our prediction the way we
make prediction of models in R is
running the predict function so R we had
a support vector machine object in R and
then we can pass in the our data
remember that our data came from a
variable that we captured from Python so
you can have variables or inputs from
Python world and then plug it into an
our model object and then of course
they're shiny what I've shown so far
we're all the pieces that you can then
input into a shiny model right you had
an art variable that can now just be a
reactive thing and then you can create a
shiny object out of this so the first
thing you want to do if you have a
Python model is you need to save this
out so there is a library called job Lib
that is essentially like pickling or
creating binary format
you can save out your Python model and
then in our you can load in that Python
model so here's an example I actually
have two slide decks this year so this
is a our markdown document using shiny
as a back-end so this is my way of
mocking up a shiny app so somewhere in
there shredding up you're going to Wayne
to library or load up articulate you're
going to find the environment that you
want to use and enable that Python
environment we can get our data from
scikit-learn so this is the exact same
code that we did before because this is
in our markdown all I did here was
wrapped us around a Python chunk instead
of an art chunk and then we can load up
the two libraries that we need to load
that Python model object so my previous
slide saved out this Python model object
and in this slide deck I am loading in
that Python model object into an R in
this case it's shining out and then
here's just the use case we can say
python model dot predict and give it
some vector you know just give us a
prediction whatever value of this row
just said that no you do not have breast
cancer so we can do the same thing in
our py dollar side model dollar sign
predicts so we can get the python model
from the Python world called the predict
function pass in variables that way so
that's all the pieces right for shiny so
now in shiny we have to have some kind
of richard object so we have an input
panel just so you see something and we
have a slider input this slider input
just all it is really doing is giving us
how many rows in the test set that will
plug in to our model to run a prediction
and so this is a py dollar sign python
model so this is an actual Python model
we are taking the Python test variable
but then here you're saying you see
input dollar sign that is a shiny
variable and so now if we move this
slider and we go to nine we get nine
predictions this is a variable this is a
shiny object that we captured
using all of the shiny framework and
we're pumping it into a into a Python
object isn't that cool
please go wow so the down ecosystem so I
showed you shiny and bits of our
markdown this pretty much works for
everything and I haven't tried it yet so
there is like that book that I wrote and
it's written in latex and like Sam said
let's not use that so there's something
called poke down so maybe I'll just
write everything in book down but it
even though it's a Python look fingers
crossed everything works blog down the
Hugo academic theme actually supports
through printer notebook so you can
actually blog with Drew printer
notebooks and it will render your
trooper notebooks in as blog post some
stuff in the Python world I guess they
realize that hey this stuff by our
studio is pretty cool so this year I
learned of a package called knit Pi or a
knit B which is the knitter
implementation in the Python world and
if you are in Jupiter notebook world
there is a system called Jupiter books
that lets you create use a Jupiter
notebook for individual book chapter
sort of works like book down but it is a
different system you can create
reticulated our packages I'm not going
to show you this but just know that the
art Kerris package is really reticulate
in Python just wrapping around the
Python API so if you load up Kerris you
probably have realized you yet we really
need an entire Python stack installed
and this is really just hey python has
all of these problems solved already
let's just you know write a nicer API on
top and that's how Karis in the art
world was created but in folks at our
studio
one thing about installing Python if you
try to come back here and follow along
is I am a software carpentry instructor
and so I always point people towards a
surfer Department tree instructions for
those of you who took my get training
yesterday you would have noticed that I
also just sent you get installation
instructions and things got a little bit
confusing in terms of
this but most people in data science
world use anaconda 3 install Python so
if you want to install Python and not
work the rest of your system give
anaconda a shot the way you uninstall it
is just the leading a folder so it's
pretty harmless in that sense one thing
about Conda so there's this wonderful
website created by Jenny Bryan and I
think Jim Hester I'm not sure folks at
our studio it's called our stats dot WTF
it's got a great URL and it's about
things they forgot to teach you about
are there is a section in there about
using condo with our and the main thing
is when you install anaconda do have the
ability to install our and our packages
within
using the Conda package installer and if
you are trying to follow along the main
suggestion is pick one of those systems
and stick with it and the one I
recommend is if you're going to install
our packages just stick in the our world
so don't mix and match countenance tall
with install that packages you will be
very confused where things are something
work to happen if you follow my talk
last year I talked about project
workflows Wes McKinney who works for
Ursula labs runs the pack runs a project
called Apache arrow so if you are
sharing objects between R and Python
give Apache arrow a shot and it is a
very fast and efficient way where you
can store and pass along data frame
objects between R and Python so if you
do have large data sets that eventually
need to be loaded into
spark or Hadoop or read and write
Parkay files look into Apache arrow and
they'll be it'll integrate very well
with your R and Python world and so that
is my talk if you want my slides there
are at the bottom of every slide deck
but if you need to take a picture here
it is
[Applause]